[Music]
welcome back river babes
I'm your Sweetwater secrets host Liana
galera and I am so darn happy to see you
now you guys it has been a month since
the last episode of Riverdale graced our
screens and I don't know about you but I
have been in an awful Cheryl worthy mood
around the et online offices while I've
been missing my favorite Riverdale IANS
Bernie you guys I think I even miss
chick just kidding he's still the
absolute worst now this is your
Sweetwater secrets preview show for
episode 2 14 chapter 27 The Hills Have
Eyes and based off of the promo which
I've now watched about a billion times
over this break it looks like things
will be getting extremely steamy for
bug-head oh yeah that's right I said bug
head as in Veronica and Jughead
but before I quench your thirst with a
tall glass of schipper aid here's your
itty-bitty Riverdale recap of chapter 26
the tell-tale heart bug had grew closer
by covering up the Cooper murder chick
wouldn't stop crying the FBI agent is
actually Hermione lodges henchman FP and
Alice are freaking perfect together
Cheryl flawlessly stood up to Hal Cooper
and help Betty prevent a fashion
emergency you have puke on your collar
damn all that feels like forever ago but
I still loved hearing all of your hisses
and kisses in the Sweetwater Secrets
comments about episode 213 so kicking
things off as Nina Bhanu said am I the
only one who found heart Denton
extremely adorable when he cried at the
dinner table as much as I hate the
character chick alright girl I'm picking
up what you're putting down but let me
clear something up just because I
despise chick with the passion of a
thousand suns doesn't mean I don't love
the actor I think heart is doing a
sensational job and my hatred for chick
is simply a complement to his acting
abilities
meanwhile Annabel Pope says I have a
feeling that chick knows that SP is his
real dad and he wants to get Hal out of
the picture excuse the pun hisses to Hal
and Penelope it's real my ass and kisses
to the Cooper Jones teamwork even if it
was just to cover up a murder okay
and you guys we had a lot of bug head
comments as well you know Kaitlyn enosis
said kisses to Jughead for being there
for Betty even though it was a full-out
murder catastrophe you know simple
Ripper don't date meanwhile dreaming
with a 1 instead of an I made me
legitimately laugh out loud by writing
kisses to Jughead for being every woman
after losing her virginity and face
Sophie shared ok guys I have a theory it
might be crazy but let's see does anyone
else think that Betty could be pregnant
you know the day after her first time
with Jughead she's sick I know could
just be because of the gruesomeness of
the murder but it's still a possibility
okay well I appreciate you thinking
outside the box girl but here's a mini
biology lesson for all you young uns out
there it takes a lot longer than just a
day before morning sickness kicks in
with the pregnancy that's not how it
works
that's not how any of this work that was
just Betty being overwhelmed by the fact
that she helped her mother hide a body
in the woods plus if you take a look at
Betty in the next episode I'm gonna let
you in on a little secret
that's not a mocktail she's drinking
lastly Curt moods said hisses - the fact
that Tony wasn't in the episode hisses
Ferno Kevin or no Josie and hisses -
Betty 4 still not telling Jughead that
she kissed Archie and cause it's to
Cheryl for showing a caring side of her
now not to worry current mood because I
have good news for you there will be
plenty of Tony in this week's episode in
fact I just got off the song with
Vanessa Morgan herself and she'll be
spilling all of the Tony tea in our next
Sweetwater secrets after-show so be sure
to check back for that but before I send
you off to watch the next episode of
Riverdale I'm gonna leave you guys with
some inside scoop on what's to come and
what's definitely the most sexy episode
of Riverdale you'll ever
see number one one character will take
things way too far at the end of the
episode number two you'll meet someone
who is even creepier than chick yes I'm
serious and number three is that there
will be three massive bombshells in this
episode one is shocking one is
heartbreaking and one will finally put
all the pieces together on a storyline
that has been neglected alright guys now
that does it for this Sweetwater secrets
preview show for chapter 27 The Hills
Have Eyes
now check back with me after you watch
the episode 214 for exclusive scoop from
Vanessa Morgan and my official freaked
out over the episodes most heated
moments but for now hits the comments or
tweet me and tell me if you can decipher
my three clues then give this video a
like hit subscribe to e t--'s youtube
channel so you never miss an episode of
Sweetwater secrets Tata for now river
babes
[Music]